when the first World War Began Italy was
aligned with the Central Powers as a
member of the Triple Alliance yet
despite its alliance with both
Austria-Hungary and the German Empire
Italy never joined the war on their side
in fact in 1915 Italy joined the
conflict on the side of the Anton and
fought against Austria-Hungary until the
end of the war three years later which
raises the question why why didn't Italy
join the Central Powers in the first
world war so when Italy came into
existence in the latter half of the 19th
century it did so in ten circumstances
the Austrian Empire next door and its
ruling family had held a great deal of
sway over the peninsula for centuries
and Italy's birth had seen them defeated
militarily and mostly pushed out of the
region to Italy's Northwest the one
sallied French wanted the same regions
of North Africa as Italy tensions
between the two sides remained high and
fearing that they couldn't win a war
with France the Italians turned to
Germany in their old adversaries in
Vienna for an alliance in 1882 Italy
signed a defensive pact with the two
empires leading to the birth of the
Triple Alliance the alliance saw the
magrita Wade the others if they were
ever invade did and both Italy and
Austria agreed that they wouldn't expand
further into the Balkans without
compensating the other the alliance was
renewed every 10 years up until 1912
which came after Austria-Hungary had
snatched Bosnia from the collapsing
Ottoman Empire in 1908. Italy wasn't
happy with this and so demanded
compensation preferably in the form of
one Albania or these territories
Austria-Hungary said no or more
specifically wait several years to see
if we stay here and as such the Italian
government considered the Triple
Alliance to be dead but they renewed it
again four years later because they
didn't want to burn bridges in case they
ever needed the backing of Vienna or
Berlin in the future this had been
Italy's foreign policy for decades at
this point since In 1902 it had signed a
secret treaty with France they agreed
that the two would never go to war with
the other in return for them respecting
each other's fears of influence in North
Africa which is why when the first world
war broke out Italy declared itself
neutral this wasn't to say it had closed
the door to Austria-Hungary in Germany
forever though its foreign policy in
1914 was dictated by one question who
can give Italy the most Germany offered
Italy this from France if it ended the
war whereas is Austria-Hungary was less
keen on Italy joining the war properly
and so offered some of its own lands to
Italy on the condition that it stayed
neutral and gave some trade concessions
whereas the Anton offered Italy all of
this a promise that it would 100 honor
after the war Italy much preferred what
Britain and France was offering and so
it signed the Treaty of London agreeing
to Wade the entente which surely meant
that Italian entry against the Central
Powers was guaranteed right well no
Antonio solandra was the Prime Minister
of Italy in 1915 but his position was
very fragile and Italy itself was
politically very divided with most
people much preferring neutrality this
wasn't out of some deep Italian love for
the Central Powers but because War sucks
and you can make a lot of money trading
with Warring States anyway salandra was
fiercely pro-ontaunt whereas the last
prime minister in salandra's main
opponent Giovanni gioletti was
pro-central Powers when the writing
looked to be on the wall gieliti met
with the German Chancellor to arrange
what he could do if he replaced salandra
knowing that if he did nothing he would
lose his job solandra did the only thing
he could he quit he did this not because
he actually wanted to to quit because he
knew that Parliament wouldn't back him
and by quitting he forced the king to
choose if the king let him resign then
the king backed the Central Powers if
the king refused to accept his
resignation then it meant to be back the
on taunt he knew that Parliament would
never act against the king's wishes at
such a time and so when the king ordered
salandra to stay in office his position
was Secure and thus Italy was free to
join the war alongside France and
Britain which he did in May 1915. I hope
you enjoyed this episode with the
special thanks to my patreon supporters
James bisonet Kelly moneymaker Sky
Chappelle call show wolf kotoitska
Adam's daughter Jerry lambdin Alex
Schwinn Jordan Longley Marcus Arsenal
rod D Martin wyan hockey Spencer
Lightfoot Captain psydog Marvin Castle
boogly Wiggly kimun Yoon Winston K wood
Aaron the white the mcwhopper Miss izet
Maggie paxkowski Gustav Swan Anthony
Beckett Coppertone shewenin spinning
three plates Charles the first and words
about books podcast